(lightning booming)
- There was a great thing that somebody
said to me years ago,
and I say it all the time.
There's two ways to build
the biggest building in town.
You either just build the
biggest building in town,
or you spend all your time
tearing everybody else's building down.
And if there's anything on my last breath
that I'm most proud of, is I'm out here
just trying to build the biggest building.
It would be the best if all eight billion
people had this mindset.
You wouldn't have a single
bad thing happen in society.
(laughs)
If you actually cared about everybody else
and didn't impose your
own hurt on someone else.
- [Interviewer] So where do we start?
Because you would say parents, maybe?
- Yeah, I think you start
with even the conversation.
We start with this fucking film.
(urban music)
I think about succeeding
in one very simple story.
There are two ways, my friends, to build
the biggest building in town.
Step number one, just build
Step number two, build
a decent-sized building
and then spend all your
time trying to tear down
everybody else's building around you down,
so you end up being the
biggest building in town.
My friend, 95% of people
try to do number two.
People that tear everyone
else's building down
are hurting inside and want other people
to feel pain, misery loves company.
And are so insecure
that they actually think
that that $1 or that
opportunity is only available.
They don't live in a world of abundance.
I do think some people think
the lives of a population,
like black lives matter more,
that means my life matters less.
And I think that's super wrong.
That's why people are replying
saying all lives matter.
They don't get it.
They think that it's like a competition
or there's space that
black lives are taking up.
People hear black privilege.
And I've been watching how
people have been acting.
They think that comes at the cost
of somebody who's white or Asian.
- Absolutely.
- That's crazy.
This is not a black,
white, girl, boy issue.
This is a positive, negative issue.
- [Man] That's it.
- It's fucking stupid.
Of course your life matters too.
How do you not understand that you should
only be as happy as your
most unhappy fellow human.
That level of compassion,
sympathy, empathy
is fucking required
for your own happiness.
How in the world does anybody translate
black lives matter in their head as
no, no, but my life matters too.
Yes, yes, yes.
But that's why this is on my mind,
because when you see
things happen socially,
it translates in my brain business-wise.
These are the same people that think
when somebody else's store opens up,
that they're gonna lose.
See, I think the problem is so many people
want to win at somebody else's expense
without understanding that there's so many
variations of winning, and every one of us
has a totally different definition for it.
And when my homie Travis from Uber,
and when my homie, Chris
Saka becomes the best VC,
and goes on "Shark Tank" and they beat me,
I'm the most pumped for them.
They deserve it.
And then I say, but it's not over yet.
(audience laughing)
And that's who I am.
- [Interviewer] Why do
some people get mad?
- Because they're sad.
Because they're selfish.
They care about themselves.
But the question is, why do
they care about themselves?
They care about themselves
because they're insecure,
and it's a protective mechanism.
Most people that come along that have
a lot of talent to amass attention
and resources and wealth and power,
a solid amount of them
lack humility and altruism.
But I think a lot of
people were also lucky
in having kindness and capability in them.
They just weren't watching something
that made them think
that was the thing to do.
That's what this is all about, right?
This is all about like,
no, I'm not that special.
There's actually millions of people
in the last 100 years that had what I had.
It's just they grew up in
societies and messaging
that made them think differently.
I think that Steve Jobs
came along, became an icon.
But the sad part of that narrative
was he did not treat his employees well.
He became an icon and
the narrative became,
he got the most out of
people by being a jerk.
And that became romanticized.
I could literally watch people that I knew
who used to be nicer start
treating employees like jerks
because that's what Steve Jobs did.
And a lot of people in
Silicon Valley today
run companies where they're mean
because they think that's
the right thing to do
because they put Steve Jobs on a pedestal.
I want my pedestal moment.
I want to become that big.
And what I want to come from that
is that kids that aren't even born today
think that they can build
a $5 billion company
and be a great guy or great gal.
And what I want to do is
inspire two 14 year old girls
in Kansas City right now to
build a billion dollar company
on having a bunch of employees
hugging each other in the halls.
I feel this crazy, weird
sense of responsibility
that I was given all this
talent and capability.
And I'm like, okay, I need
to communicate how I do it,
because I do think I do
it with a more empathetic,
sympathetic, compassionate,
human, good intent.
If you asked me point
blank, do I feel like
I've already moved the
collective entrepreneurial world
a little bit, a hair towards it?
I do because I've just
had hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds and
thousands of entrepreneurs
reach out to me and
say, I'm a better person
because of this or that.
And I think the more successful I am,
the more people will try
to parrot that behavior.
So I think positivity and
good is practical advice
to building an empire.
And I wanna be the poster
child of the person
that built the biggest, baddest empire
and did it by being a
good dude along the way.
And that's the legacy I want to leave.
Let me make it perfectly clear to you.
The world is abundant.
Nobody else is taking out of your pocket.
Everybody who's watching
this film right now,
if you're good enough,
nothing's gonna stop ya.
♪ Why would you run from
me, run from me yeah ♪
♪ You could just run
to me, run to me yeah ♪
♪ The feeling's electric ♪
♪ Why would you run from
me, run from me yeah ♪
♪ You could just run
to me, run to me yeah ♪
♪ The feeling's electric ♪